la démocratie n'a pas de prix mais elle
a un coût et
euh le les quand il il est absolument
anormal que plus de la moitié des maires
de France perdent de l'argent en
devenant maire parce que c'est la
réalité beaucoup cumulent avec un job
hein notamment dans les petites commune
euh qui reprente le tissu euh euh
majoritaire des communes de France et
l'indemnité elle est euh de inférieur au
SMIC nettement inférieur au SMIC hein et
et c'est pas normal et et ça on peut le
regarder en face c'estàd que beaucoup de
patriotique compris de ceux qui galèrent
d'abord pensent que les Maes gagnent
beaucoup plus sont très surpris du
montant de l'adimité notamment dans les
petites communes et euh c'est c'est
complètement marginal en terme de
dépenses et et aujourd'hui il faudrait
qu'un maire qui a une fonction exécutive
une responsabilité civile politique et
pénale et la capacé et et un revenu de
au moins de cadres moyens quoi enfin
c'est c'est c'est ne soit pas perdant
parce que ça contribue à dévaloriser
cette fonction qui est pourtant la plus
belle de la République française il y a
un nombre record de d'émissions de maire
et de conseillers municip 40 par mois de
maire rien que les maires c'est 40 par
mois en moyenne est-ce que vous craignez
vous alertez sur une crise d'évocation
pour 2026 euh nous sommes encore le pays
où il y a le plus de vocation parce
qu'on a ce tissu de de de commune qui
est unique et qui est une richesse à
tous les sens du terme d'ailleurs mais
oui oui parce que vous savez j'en
discute avec des maires et c'est pas que
dans les villages dans des villages
parfois on a du mal à boucler la liste
en plus il y a un problème de
surreprésentation c'estàd que le le le
nombre d'élus par rapport au nombre
d'habitants est demandé dans les
conseils municipaux est beaucoup plus
fort dans les villages donc ça il faut
qu'on le revoit il y a beaucoup de
sénateurs qui travaillent là-dessus
d'ailleurs à juste titre mais même dans
les grandes villes mais y compris à
Paris moi j'ai discuté avec des
représentants de grands partis hein de
partis majoritair en France qui ont du
mal parfois à boucler des listes de
qualité équilibré et cetera dans des
grands arrondissements donc il peut y
avoir problème de vocation mais y
compris dans les très grandes
villes